and it wait hold up oh God three types of what
uh I don't know that was a trick that's fast
I don't know why you put the time up there
can you name three Harry Potter characters
um Harry Potter herione and Ron Wesley weey uh
Harry Potter Hermione and uh stor SLI uh Ron
Weasley uh Harry Potter Dumbledore Harry
Potter Maloy and the teacher Dobby Harry
Potter and uh the girl Margaret maybe I do I
do not know Harry Potter Harry Potter um Harry
Potter uh Dumbledore that's Hermione Harry heg
Harry Potter Hermione Granger Ron Wesley Harry
Potter that's one I don't know Harry Ron Hermione
I'm a Harry Potter guy name three NHL teams based
in New York Islanders devils and the Rangers I got
Buffalo actually that was a trick one yeah Rangers
Islanders and Savers Rangers Islanders Devils
aren't based in New York but close enough so
actually the third team Buffalo whatever Sabers
Islanders Rangers Buffalo Rangers Islanders New
Jersey Islanders Rangers is it correct Buffalo
oh yeah of course it's Buffalo Islanders Rangers
Devils Islanders Rangers Devils Rangers Devils
Islanders Buffalo oh yeah oh je New Jersey uh
the Rangers the Islanders New York Islanders New
York Rangers New Jersey Devils New Jersey Devils
Islanders Devils Rangers No actually is that right
that is not right Rangers Islanders what's the
third one Buffalo oh god well New Jersey's closer
than yeah y Rangers Islanders and in there Buffalo
no no no no does that work that totally you got it
right every you say in New Jersey it's not right
no that that's correct yeah name three snacks
uh lace chips Cheetos and H dip goldfish Oreos
gummy bears chips chocolate and apple orange
banana chips candy Pizza granola bars fruit
uh two for three Cheez hits Pringles sour patch
chips candy bar popcorn pretzels chips peanuts
you name three planets Earth Mars Jupiter Earth
Mars Venus Earth Saturn Jupiter Earth Mars Pluto
Pluto is no longer a planet Mars Earth Jupiter
Earth Mercury Jupiter Mercury Venus Earth Mars
Saturn and Uranus uh Earth Mars and Jupiter Moon
Earth and Mars is the moon not a planet Earth Moon
Jupiter is Jupiter not a planet anymore or which
one's on a planet unless Chang where where are you
from